can you describe your typical writing
day
yeah so i said i
i find that i get
a lot of good stuff down earlier my
brain just is more lucid i think uh
because it's it maybe is because i'm
coming off of like a
um sleep so six
seven six seven to nine a.m is where i
think i write my
right my best um that's me personally
and
uh i would just tackle tackle that and
try to write some days like some days um
i could get four pages some days i'll
get half a page
but when i'm finishing up a script um
i write till like
two or three from that moment so try to
get a good eight hour
get eight hours in sometimes i'll stare
at the page or i'm researching
or on on talking things out or writing
out but
when i'm finished working on a script i
i
i try to do that a good amount like a
good study amount each day
um the rewrites uh when i'm doing
rewrites
so after just um recently
we just did a read through so we'll have
it read through
see how it sounds uh because sometimes
when you read a script
you read it faster or slower so when you
have someone who just reads it
out you could get a better time if it's
the scenes too long if everyone's
tweeting their thumb and going like hey
let's wrap this up
that's when we you could tell we want to
cut it
cut it up more and make it faster so
we'll do a read through
and then we'll have notes and then i'll
go through
wake up and uh
send some emails but then i'll go
through the notes
and and and knock knock it out you know
and go hey
uh this we need to add a little more
humor here or hey we got to do this or
cut this out or this is a
three-page scene um we need to
you know trim it down so i would work
those angles so
um again the earlier the better for me
so i could you know
it doesn't seem like um my brain works a
little bit better that
that way when you do the read through or
you have someone else do it
are they reading with no emotion yeah
they're just reading it through so they
don't have to act it out
they could just you know read scene
headings seeing this and sometimes they
you know they'll get into an act but
they don't have to be it doesn't have to
be like a table root of everything but
just go interior um
jacob's kitchen so-and-so comes in you
know then
and they're they'll just read it normal
yeah so so we could see the pacing and
then
if there's a issue where they want to go
it's like hey
does he really have does he really say
yes ma'am right now he said
it three yes ma'am three three three
you know pages ago or something i don't
think he's gonna say yes ma'am now so
you could really
kind of work on dialogue too and that it
just
sounds a little bit off or forced you
know so it every
everyone would have like an idea and me
as a writer i'll take the notes
and go um you know and
that helps that helps because when you
when you guys are
reading in your head
sometimes you get stuck you know so it's
nice to kind of hear it
hear the words out it doesn't have to be
acted out but
but that gives you a better time frame
um so i recommend that if you get even a
friend
after you finish something having to
read through um
it took the last three three took us
about
we started 11 and finished it at like
four
you know because you're going through
each word each page each word
we have a stop you know and you go oh
what do you think about that
you know things like that so that really
helped
there's a new new job description in the
pandemic yeah
have a job as a reader yeah just read it
through on zoom or something yeah
yeah absolutely nice because um
you know it's better to have someone
versus a writer
read it or you know director so you
could sit there
have your team of collaborators a
producer director whoever
and so they could hear it hear it out
once you start writing a screenplay
how often do you write how often do you
go to write it
so page one of something you're getting
up at six in the morning maybe
you're excited and then maybe you're
stopping at nine a.m
depending on your schedule and then how
often are you going back to it
during the day um during the course of
however long it takes you to finish so
whether it's a year
10 years i just did i just finished uh
one uh it took me about
four months um and i
spent um every day pretty much at it
for about average of like four to
five hours a day on it so
um that one yeah so it depends
like i said the always to perla look how
long it took
but now as you get better and you're
more confident of
of of what you want and the structure of
the scenes and things like that
and um i had in my head of like
what stephen king always says of like
you don't wait for inspiration you just
get to work you know so even if i'm
staring at the page
or something on zone in i'm
i'm focusing on it so i i wanted to kind
of just keep chiseling it
um and and sometimes you get great
breakthroughs you know and you'll write
a good amount
but um it's
it's it's different for each one for the
last couple ones
i'll be disciplined on that like um i
just try to treat myself like a
like an athlete if i had to go do this
for if
in a day what would so and so i hear you
know
let's say like um i just read something
it was just on jimmy butler from miami
he
gets he said he was up at 3 or 4 a.m
practicing
or something like that so i want i
wanted to implement those kind of
like um practices they all say like
um i i try to do things that that
that you don't want to do because
they're usually good for you
and then so it's like i don't want to
wake up every day and do this but
um but if you love it and if you're
challenged by it
it's it's not that painful um so uh
i'm fortunate to kind of go oh awesome
you know i'm gonna work on on this um
meanwhile we're also trying to
run um you know commercials and things
like that so you have to balance
kind of different things and stuff and
and doing that
and you might not have um
uh certain weeks where you can but i'll
try to at least slide something in
maybe in it maybe it's 2 am to 4
4 you know afterwards um but at least
i'll try to put the hours in
um for for writing
yeah well so you have writings
occasionally at 2 a.m
yeah sometimes yeah sometimes yeah
because you're like
you're just so um you're just so
kind of addicted to it because like you
know you're in the cup
if you're just in the cusp of breaking
through the scene
you know and just get it out and then
you can come back later and elevate it
you know and
and just and texturize it and do this
but
but you're in a roll you know and like
if you keep getting rolls
then you'll get to that 90 page 100 page
and you're like ah i finished
and let it sit and now you could work on
the rewrite afterwards
you